يتخوف ثلث سكان اقليم دارفور من ضياع
الموسم الزراعي لهذا العام نسبه لصراع
المستمر بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
فانعدام الامن بالاراضي الزراعيه المطريه
والمرويه يمثل احد ابرز المهددات
للمزارعين عطفا على خروج المنظمات وانعدام
البذور وضع لم يحدث منذ سنوات الحرب
باقليم دارفور ازرعت دائره امنيه ودائره
استقرار ودائره مسائل كثيره فنحن كان
ولايه دارفور ونحن من دارفور عموما السنه
بالنقدر نزرع وما بنقدر نحاول انه الزراعه
لانه امينه ما في وما مستقرين في الامن
وايجاد نظره متدهوره
توقف العديد من المهند الرئيس صراع الدائر
بالسودان جعل بعض المزارعين يتركون فكره
الزراعه هذا العام ويلجاون الى مخزونهم
الزراعي كغذاء او بيعه في السوق لجلب
المستلزمات اليوميه في هذه الظروف الحرجه
التي تمر بها البلاد انا شخصيا كمزارع او
خفت ناس البيت من الزراعه نسبه للمشاكل
السنه
عندي
البهائم اللي بنزرع بها دخلتها السوق
اجبرتها ناس البيت على اساس انه ما يزرق
نسبه للودي المار به البلد
وزرقوا الزراعتي واتحادات والمزارعين
يقولون انه لا حلول تلوح في الطريق بعد
انعدام التمويل الزراعي نسبه لتوقف
المصارف بسودان التمويل الذي يعتمد عشرات
المزارعين عليه في التشغيل والمدخلات وانا
شخصيا بتوقع انه الموسم ده فاشل بنسبه
200% لانه ما في جيب عشان كذا حتى القبول
المزارعين على الزراعه السنه
قبول تعبان جدا لانه ما عندهم قروش وما في
جيبه لهم احنا عندنا
21 مليون فاصل ثلاثه مليون راس من الماشيه
فلا جنوب دارفور هو مساحات شاسعه مليون
فدان صالح للزراعه حقيقه هذه اكثر من 24
مليون
هكتار عربي يعني ده كلها تاثرت
بالحرب ده يعتبر فصل الخريف هو فصل
التحصيل الغذائي لسكان دارفور في المدني
ومعسكرات النزوح الصراع الان في السودان
بحسب مراقبين تنذروا بوضع كارثي ربما
يستمر لسنوات طويله صالح ابو علامه لقناتي
العربيه والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه
السودان لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات